c'est confiné d'ici d'ailleurs et
aujourd'hui vous emmène au luxembourg un
tout petit pays se trouve juste à côté
de la france paris retrouvé tatiana
welmant une martiniquaise qui s'y
installer et l'entretien n'a comment ça
va de ton côté
on est au luxembourg alors on connaît
pas forcément on a déjà entendu le nom
mais on ne sait pas où ça se trouve
exactement par rapport à la france
c'est tout hippiques en france belgique
alors comment est-ce qu'on quitte la
martinique et comment ce qu'on trouve
dans ce petit pays pas loin de la france
c'était pas du tout prévu avec mon
compagnon nous a toujours partir en
suisse et la montée en fait des maps
smic est une application bancaire jeudi
cette bêtise et du coup le champ vous en
faites permettait des bâtiments et pour
créer extincteur
donc oui d'autant plus que c'est là qu'a
commencé thèbes à l'extérieur on s'est
retrouvé là on a près de lui
qu'est ce qu'il ya de beau à voir au
luxembourg
on découvre un petit peu en profite de
fait de t'avoir en ligne pour voir si
c'est une destination qu'on peut
rajouter à notre carnet de voyage alors
ses accès c'est très petit mais c'est un
très vieux les petits pays tous
impliqués très propre et vous fait
beaucoup penser à la suisse
j'ai très développé dans le secteur dans
lequel bien évidemment et j'étais
lapacca plainte je fais habituellement
non parce que ce serait mentir mais
l'avantagé c'est d'être contaminés avec
plein pianoter d'accéder très facilement
à la belgique à l'allemagne
et ça c'est vraiment super agréable
alors toi tu as à la limite en fait je
suis un cadre unique du luxembourg à 35
minutes de l'allemagne 45 de la belgique
est ce qu'il ya un confinement chez vous
au luxembourg en ce moment ou pas alors
oui à partir de demain à munich hambourg
ce dimanche parce qu'ils ont pris plus
de mesures que la france est ce qui est
assez compliquée par rapport au fait
d'être frontaliers c'est qu'on a le luxe
ont donc il fonctionne d'une façon et la
france qui fonctionnent d'une autre
façon je savais un peu de son mot ils
ont distribué des masques dans toute
maison chaque habitant a reçu des
masques
ils ont pris des mesures très
draconiennes pour le travail parce qu'il
faut savoir que attendant tous les jours
en temps normal il ya entre 100 et 200
et frontaliers qui vient travail ou
qu'ils rentrent chez eux le soir trois
quarts de leur grille et enfin du
personnel et soit français et petit à
petit tu es conseiller en image
oui comment est-ce qu'on va arriver à
travailler quand on ne peut pas être au
contact des autres qu'est-ce que tu
arrives pendant cette période de ducobu
19 à continuer à exercer son activité
professionnelle
[Musique]
je travaille avec des belges pour une
marque de beauté ma faim avec soin et
dès le début et c'est ce qui m'a très
étonné c'est que par rapport à
l'ancienne en entreprise sont en
belgique
ils ont fait très mal et août beaucoup
d'échangés d'ailleurs plus déroutant
parce que les belges sont très familiers
et par rapport à mon activité
professionnelle dans un premier temps
début de co2 dues prochainement je me
suis dit ça n'allait pas durer quand
j'ai continué à travers mes clients en
faisant beaucoup de vision par le biais
du jour ou pas de vision pour continuer
à les accompagner pour les rassurer
parce qu'on est l'accompagnement
coiffure maquillage etc
mais c'est vrai que là j'avais un petit
port bou bascule c'est d'abord un métier
de contact
même si les champignons contrat c'est
vraiment important pour moi de garder ce
métier relationnel avec nous parce que
c'est ce qu'elle belle
contrairement à d'autres qui propose bon
on espère en tout cas un retour à la
normale au plus vite de façon à ce que
justement à ces secteurs d'activité
puisque recommencé à travailler c'est
vrai que c'est pas évident depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois ces
métiers de contact comme tu disais tout
à l'heure de soins à la personne où
c'est pas ce n'est pas forcément évident
on attend de voir comment comment ça
évolue et que tu puisse reprendre son
activité professionnelle pleinement en
tout cas merci de ce petit voyage au
luxembourg alors c'est vrai que l'on n'y
ai pas pensé spontanément et en bâtir un
jour on partira en vacances là bas
du coup on ira jeter un petit coup
d'oeil visiter voir et puis qui sait ce
sera peut-être l'occasion de faire une
belle
une belle rencontre avec un beau pays
merci à toi tatiana pour la petite
visite
et puis prends soin de toi soyez prudent
bien les
avant jusqu'à la fin de tout ça et puis
on espère te revoir quand même très
bientôt en martinique j'imagine que
forcément on fait des allers-retours et
dossier on espère très vite tout bon bah
écoute a très vite alors merci beaucoup
tatiana tatiana vail non qui nous a fait
découvrir aujourd'hui le luxembourg
merci à vous également de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite sur la
première